[Music]
after months of waiting on september
16th
2020 star wars fans celebrated the first
teaser trailer for the mandalorians
incoming second season
in true mando fashion the sneak peek was
action-packed visually stunning
and gave viewers no shortage of baby
yoda footage to enjoy
should we offer that thing some water
you just want to look at it
so what you got to see it the trailer
established that the plot of the new
season revolves around the little green
guy's mandalorian caretaker
attempting to deliver him to his home be
that his actual planet of origin or that
of the sorcerers known as the jedi
of course such a journey wouldn't be
complete without a few curveballs and
detours along the way
the mandalorian whose real name is
dingerin and his foundling child may
have to come
face to face with some of the galaxy's
most high profile names during season 2.
ahsoka tano and bojitan cries are set to
appear in the new season
and speculation has run rampant that
even more familiar faces will make their
way to live action
on the disney plus series since
lucasfilm announced a mandalorian
fans have clamored for boba fett to make
an appearance at least once
during the show's run now if the eagle
light star wars fan base is correct
there's an actual easter egg alluding to
boba fett in the trailer for the
mandalorian season 2.
a lot happens in the mandalorian season
2 teaser trailer
ranging from the appearance of
mysterious hooded figures to darcy or
bantha's returning to star wars media
as a result of its breakneck pace there
are quite a few
and your missing moments that have a lot
to say about what this season will
entail
as reported by comicbook.com one such
moment lasts for just a few frames
drawing the scene featuring someone
riding a speeder bike and a
tatooine-like planet
many fans on twitter think that on the
back of this speeder is a jet pack that
resembles the one famously worn by boba
fett
the last fans saw off vet in return of
the jedi the sarlacc of the great pit of
carcoon
appeared to have swallowed him up
looking closely the jet pack in the
teaser trailer appears to have the same
muted orange and blue green color scheme
as the one boba fett wore
in the sixth installment of the
skywalker saga especially taking into
consideration the damage it likely
endured from the sarlacc
and all the dust that's coating it the
question many have about this possible
glimpse of boba fett's pack is he will
be wearing it
if it's not the man himself perhaps
someone somehow came across the
undigested jet pack in the desert
and kept it for themselves it could be
jarring but there are reports that
someone new will take up fed's iconic
garb in the mandalorian
at least for a time back in may 2020 the
news broke that deadwood star timothy
oliphant would join the castle the
mandalorian season 2
in an undisclosed role an anonymous
inside source allegedly told the folks
at slash film that olly
fund was spotted on set in fed's
distinctive gear suggesting that whoever
his character is he will take ownership
of the discarded armor
and masquerade as a bounty hunter
there's actually precedent for this in
the current star wars canon as chuck
wendig's novel aftermath introduces
kobanth
a tatooine sheriff who buys the salvaged
outfit from some jawas
if fett is actually alive like he was in
the now non-canonical star wars expanded
universe of books
and other media maybe he'll work
alongside dinjarin to recover his
missing gear
or maybe jaren will take it upon himself
to put a stop to olefin's character
making a mockery of mandalorian armor
time will tell
from the moment he first appeared in the
star wars holiday special back in 1978
fans became instantly enamored with the
mysterious bounty hunter
his live-action appearances in both the
empire strikes back
and return of the jedi only increased
their fascination despite his limited
screen time
this led to countless stories and comics
centering on him from the old expanded
universe
now known as star wars legends these old
tales made boba fett the legend fans
perceive him to be
and they contribute greatly to how they
view him to this day as of the making of
this video there's not much in the new
chronology regarding boba fett
and nothing guarantees the survival post
return of the jedi the mandalorian can
change that and continue his story
and while the show might just be nodding
to a fan favorite character
recent rumblings around the internet
point to something more substantial
between this revelation
and the announcement of timuera morrison
the actor behind django fett and all of
his clones in the prequel trilogy
signing on for the mandalorian's second
season the return of boba fett might
only be a short weight away
the mandalorian season 2 premieres on
disney plus on october 30th
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the mandalorian are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you